[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute zeige ich euch
wie ihr gebratene asiatische nudeln ganz
einfach selber machen könnt die
gebratenen nudeln habe ich mit leckerem
gemüse und einer selbst gemachten süß
saurer soße zubereitet nun zeige ich
euch aber die zutaten wir benötigen
asiatische minute außerdem glasnudeln
neutrales öl bambussprossen die sind
bereits in scheiben geschnitten
maiskolben die habe ich halbiert und
sojabohnen keimlinge an frischem gemüse
habe ich mir die habe ich in kleine
stifte geschnitten außerdem brokkoli und
für den brokkoli benötigen wir salz und
zucker
außerdem frühlingszwiebeln und
selbstgemachte süß saurer soße
das rezept für die süß saurer soße
findet ihr oben rechts in der infoguard
und ich verlinke es euch auch nochmal
unten in der infobox nun bereiten wir
zuallererst nach packungsanleitung die
nudeln zu und ich nehme immer ganz gerne
zuerst die glasnudeln und dann die
anderen nudeln damit ich die restlos aus
dem wasser entfernen kann
[Musik]
nach etwa zwei minuten nehmen wir die
glasnudeln aus dem wasser und legen die
minuten hinein
[Musik]
diese nudeln brauchen etwa vier minuten
ihr könntet statt der minuten auch
andere wok nudeln nehmen und sobald sie
dann fertig gegart sind gießen wir sie
am spülbecken ab und hier gebe ich euch
einen ganz entscheidenden tipp anders
als bei normaler pasta solltet ihr bei
asiatischen nudeln immer gründlich mit
wasser die stärke ausspielen damit sie
später auch beim anbraten nicht kleben
nun geht es auch schon weiter mit dem
nächsten zutaten in einer separaten
pfanne hat sich etwas leitungswasser und
gebe dem brokkoli mit hinein zum
brokkoli geben wir noch salz und zucker
und lassen das etwa eine minute lang an
diensten damit sie auch noch schön
knackig bleiben anschließend bitte nicht
vergessen die herdplatte für den
brokkoli auszuschalten damit sie euch
nicht verbrennen
[Musik]
in einem größeren beschichteten topf
habe ich bereits das öl erhitzt und gebe
die möhren und die lauchzwiebeln mit
dazu
[Musik]
nachdem alles ein bis zwei minuten lang
angebraten wurde geben wir die
bambussprossen die maiskolben und die
sojabohnen keimlinge mit hinzu nachdem
alles gut miteinander verrührt wurde
geben wir die asiatischen nudeln mit
hinzu und braten sie gut an
dadurch dass wir sie vorher gut
abgespielt haben kleben sie jetzt auch
nicht und man kann sie ohne probleme
anbraten
in der zwischenzeit schneide ich die
glasnudeln drei bis viermal durch damit
man sich später besser essen kann
die glasnudeln kommen jetzt auch noch
mit in die pfanne
sie müssen allerdings nicht angebraten
sondern nur gut untergerührt werden
[Musik]
nun geben wir noch dem brokkoli mit
hinzu und anschließend unsere süß saurer
soße und verrühren alles gut miteinander
[Musik]
und nun sind die gebratene nudeln auch
schon fertig und können direkt serviert
werden
[Musik]
selbstverständlich könnt ihr das ganze
auch mit hähnchenbrust servieren hierfür
einfach das hähnchen mit salz und
pfeffer in etwas öl anbraten und
anschließend unter rühren uns persönlich
schmecken mittlerweile die
selbstgemachten asiatische nudeln viel
besser als die gekauften den brokkoli
kann ich noch ganz gut mit den stäbchen
essen und da hat aber leider auch schon
auf und ich greife lieber zugabe
schreibt auch gern mal in die kommentare
wie ihr eure asiatischen nudeln am
liebsten ist
am nächsten tag schmecken die gebratenen
nudeln übrigens genauso frisch und
lecker wie am vortag
[Musik]
falls ihr keines meiner videos mehr
verpassen möchte dann hinterlasst mir
doch gerne ein kostenloses abo übrigens
ist dieser rezeptvorschlag über
instagram entstanden und falls ihr mir
dort noch nicht folgt dann könnt ihr das
jetzt gerne nachholen und ich freue mich
wenn ihr beim nächsten mal auch wieder
dabei sein